as for Ryan Gosling well he's 42 a dad
to two girls with Ava Mendes and making
some big reveals
[Applause]
giving us rugged cowboy and bearing arms
in this new GQ photo shoot Ryan does a
total 180 from his plastic abtastic kin
in Barbie out July 21st his response to
haters who said he was too old to be
cast as kin if people don't want to play
with my kin there are many other kins to
play with Ken's got no money he's got no
job
he's got no car he's going through some
stuff so why'd he take on the
headline-making role alongside Margot
Robbie he says quote you have thought
about kin before the fourth no you
didn't you never did you never cared
that's the point
Gosling adds his daughter's playing with
the doll also had something to do with
it saying I did see him like face down
in the mud and it was like this guy's
story does need to be told so cool in
the magazine on Stan's June 13th Ryan
makes some rare comments about his
relationship quote I wasn't thinking
about kids before I met her but after I
met Ava I realized that I just didn't
want to have kids without her how are
you gonna take care
the pair met before playing parents back
in 2011 and Ryan says there were moments
on The Place Beyond the Pines where we
were pretending to be a family and I
didn't really want it to be pretend
anymore
he adds that after the birth of second
daughter Amada in 2016 he took a
four-year break from Hollywood I wanted
to spend as much time as I could with
them I haven't done red carpets in so
long and I kind of you know we miss you
by the way oh that's very sweet I don't
miss you
we talked to Ava back in 2019 about
stepping back too she and Ryan don't
have a nanny and whenever he has doubts
as a dad quote I just lean on Ava she
knows what's important always I don't
push anything on them you want to wear
your jammies to the market wear your
jammies to the market